Once you finish running that, you will see another table.
This table shows the actual data that has been loaded to memory.
The top row gives you the names of various columns in the pandas data frame.
Each column consists of an npi array.
If you're not familiar with pandas data frames,
we have linked to a lesson in the intro to data science where it
will teach you the high level concepts and about pandas and data frames.
If you scroll further down, you will see it shows five rows and
twenty eight columns.
The 28 columns indicate there are 28 vectors in the Pandas Data Frame.
Use the box below to write a python code that uses the file for
California included in your instructor's notes.
Load it to memory as a Pandas Data Frame and print a summary of the data.
Once you have finished writing your code in this box provided here,
click on this box.